بشكل عام تمثل نسخه جي بي تي 4 تحسنا
كبيرا عن سابقاتها حيث تم تدريبه على
مجموعه بيانات اكبر بكثير واكثر تنوعا
واصبح نموذجا محدثا بالمعلومات واجابته
اكثر دقه كما يتمتع بقدرات لغويه اقوى هذا
جعله اداه اكثر قوه لانشاء المحادثات بل
ايضا يتعامل مع لغات اكثر في العدد يمكن
قراءه الصور وفهمها بينما النسخ السابقه
اختصرت على النصوص ايضا يصعب خداعه وتجنب
المطالبات الخبيثه وهو ما طالب مستخدمون
من شركه اوبن اي بتدريب النسخ الجديده على
تطويرها بعيدا عن الشر يحتوي جيبيتي فور
على ذاكره اطول سيتذكر ما تحدثتما عنه في
عشرين صفحه سابقه من الدردشه من الدردشه
وقد يشير الى محادثات تمت قبل 35
صفحه اخيرا يتمتع ببنيه شبكه عصبيه اكثر
قوه تمكنه من معالجه المعلومات باستجابات
اسرع بل شبيهه بالبشر في مطالبات معينه
[موسيقى]